إنها قصة لها تأثير مضاعف
وانعكاسات تتجاوز بكثير
أسواق الطاقة فقط ، لكن هذا مثير للاهتمام
لأن ما أوجدته روسيا والسعوديون
بشكل فعال هو المزيد من
الضغط على الولايات المتحدة
أكبر لاعب ناتج هنا
لتقديم القليل من الدعم بشكل فعال
هنا  تحدث إلينا من خلال ما نراه
جيدًا ، إنه مثير للاهتمام أيضًا تحركات السوق ، ارتفع
جولي أننا ارتفعنا بنسبة 24 في المائة
أمس ، وارتفع التداول الآسيوي
بنسبة سبعة في المائة أخرى تلاشى
سريعًا في المقام الأول في الكلمات الواردة من روسيا
التي يقترحون أنهم مستعدون
للحديث ، علينا إيجاد حل وسط هنا
بين روسيا والمملكة العربية السعودية وإلى
وجهة نظرك أعتقد أنه مثلث
بين الولايات المتحدة وروسيا
والمملكة العربية السعودية في هذه المرحلة وما
حدث هنا هو أن السعودية ركزت
على استراتيجية مختلفة تمامًا.
فتح الصنابير كما تعلم أنهم خفضوا
الأسعار لعملائهم المفضلين أيضًا
وهم يقترحون أن ننظر إلى أننا لسنا
المنتج الأول في العالم  orld
لكننا المنتج الأقل تكلفة ، فلماذا
هذه الحالة للوصول إلى رقم
واحد هنا حول منتجي الصخر الزيتي في الولايات المتحدة الذين تحتاجهم ،
لمعرفة حوالي مليون
برميل يوميًا تم التخلص منها في عام 2020
، أعتقد عند التحدث إلى
مصادر سعودية  إنهم يرغبون في رؤية
مليون آخرين يخسرون بعد ذلك
لوضعهم في المركز الأول وجعل الولايات المتحدة
وروسيا تتنافسان على المركز الثاني
هنا من الآن فصاعدًا ، ترى بالفعل
مجموعة ConocoPhillips مجموعة من المنتجين متوسطي الحجم
في الولايات المتحدة بالإضافة إلى
تخفيض  لقد
بدأوا بالفعل في رؤية انخفاض الإنتاج لدى
جوليا ، لذلك كان له
تأثير واعتقدت أننا سنحصل على ما يزيد عن 30
دولارًا للبرميل لكل علامة تجارية اليوم ، فهذا لا
يحدث لأن الثقة ليست
موجودة ، نعم هناك  هناك الكثير مما يحدث ،
هذا مجرد جزء صغير من
مشكلة أكبر تحدث في الوقت
الحالي وعندما نلقي بكلمات
مثل الكساد الركود ، فإن كل ما
يجري لمحاولة استخراج
النفط ربما يكون  قضية جانبية في هذه المرحلة ،
ماذا عن الأشخاص الذين يعيدون التفكير هنا ،
ربما يكون لدى الروس
أفكار أخرى ، هل السعوديون متمسكون
وماذا عن الضغط على الكونجرس لأن
رئيسك ترامب قال إنه لا
يريد التدخل وأراد جميع
الأسعار التي لا يمكنك خفضها.  تبكي
عندما تنخفض كثيرًا ،
فأنت تعلم أنها تفكر في Trulia
لأن الولايات المتحدة تحب سعر الذهبيلوكس
بين 45 ويقول 65 دولارًا للبرميل
كان لديهم ذلك عندما تتفق السعودية وروسيا
حتى تتمكن من إيقاف ذلك
لأن هذا لن يحدث
والتدخلات  في الولايات المتحدة يتحدثون
عنه الآن أو ليس لديهم أي
علاقة بالسوق الحرة ، نسمع أولئك الموجودين في
الكونجرس يقترحون أنه يجب أن يكون هناك
حظر استيراد على روسيا السعودية ويمثل
خام أوبك بشكل عام غير
عادي حوالي 30 ٪ من إجمالي الواردات من
قبل الولايات المتحدة.  اثنان كان لدينا
13 عضوًا في مجلس الشيوخ من دول النفط والغاز
مباشرة إلى ولي عهد المملكة
العربية السعودية قائلين إن عليك
إعادة التفكير في الاستراتيجية الآن
الجانب الجيوسياسي لهذا مثير للاهتمام للغاية ،
فقد حصل ولي العهد على الكثير
من الدعم من دونالد ترامب خلال السنوات
الثلاث الماضية على الاتفاقية الأمنية مع
إيران ، حيث كان قادرًا على شراء أسلحة عندما واجه
مشاكل مع جمال خاشقجي عندما
فعل فندق ريتز كارلتون 400 في الفندق.  فيما
يتعلق بالاعتقالات ، لم يغمض دونالد ترامب أبدًا
أنه رئيس معاملات
، لقد عاد إلى ولي
العهد الآن ويقول إنه حان وقت الاسترداد ،
لا يمكنك الذهاب إلى هذا الحد وإلحاق الضرر بي
خلال عام الانتخابات خاصة في
أيام النفط والغاز التي  تمثل حوالي 10
ملايين وظيفة في جميع أنحاء الاقتصاد